previously on raft remember how I said I
wasn't gonna put the steering thing way
up high yes yeah [ __ ] that now you're
putting it way up I like to be a captain
I like to be a tall captain
all right I got you a person don't tell
Bob
thank you I won't say a word don't tell
Bob whoa what is that I'm doing really
important stuff guys good
it doesn't happen wow what the hell hit
me it was also a bird dropping actual
bombs on my head and I don't like it
that's what hit me I see
rabbit now do you want me to grab it at
the zip line yeah grab it grab it
do you guys have a captain's Hut
hey there's a turkey here there's a
turkey we could catch a turkey look at
my man
oh I killed it oh I killed it this is
mine you have to ask her to come in here
I don't you sure you don't want to check
it out did you did you want me to oh
yeah yeah of course uh
[Music]
right inside where the wind blows I
don't know where these others at Blind
Horse would be I've explored pretty much
everywhere oh we need to go underwater
for this one I forgot about that one and
then there's so many Blowfish down below
there Wade all right Wade are you ready
for your undersea Adventure where am I
going where are you underwater have fun
somewhere around here there's a place
yeah it might be on the other side of
the island
where am I it's getting real dark guys
should I wait till morning is is your
headlight not working because yeah I
mean the door is still awfully dark
kind of put a lot of work in on that
I well I I'm gonna set you up first
you're welcome for the help I guess all
right cool man
uh uh oh wait you passed it I think
maybe not let me check okay uh no keep
going you did not pass it great
you got this buddy I don't know what it
is but I'll find it oh it's the zipline
part or something no actually it's like
an underwater pipe for a water puzzle
that's right there's a pipe there's a
pipe you gotta find then you follow the
pipe down yeah that's it under the
yeah look for a pipe
also just so you know the shark is with
you the shark is with you it's with us
all and also with you thanks
I'm just gonna burn through this
headlight real quick
how fast is that uh happening not super
super not super fast but faster than I'd
like well at least it's not Cooper yeah
that would be a shame Blowfish get them
don't mess it up blow it correctly I
don't forget how many hits this takes is
it two or three it's not a lot
well it's not three four these are three
or four that's what I said
oh I'm out of oxygen what happened to
this tank well it only it only extends
yeah it extends it doesn't well how long
have I been dying is the question the
shark is not with you so you got that
going for you yeah that's pretty cool
Mark I'm so glad that you killed the
bird thanks it was annoying you want to
hear the tail no there I was on Bee
Mountain it was a mountain of bees okay
you wouldn't even understand the Peril I
was in but I had been so inured you
don't you can yeah do the sting of the
bee it didn't even phase me because of
the Rocks belting my skull I scavenged
for maybe weeks even amongst the
dangerous of the previous civilization
that used to be here and I saw lurking
beneath the ravages of society as they
crumbled down around these poor poor
people there was a bow
I said to myself with God's might
infused into this Arrow I shall smite
thee from the skies and I drew and I
pulled and I waited until I saw the
gleam
ego in this bird's eye
and then I said this one's for my father
and my mother and my brother and all of
my friends
they might have been hey I found a pipe
and loosed the arrow it flew through the
air faster than the bird could even
think faster than the bird could ever
hope to fly maybe in its dreams which it
won't have anymore because it struck it
right through its brain huh I have
killed three Blowfish and found a pipe
and then and it fell it fell
precipitously from the sky beautiful
even time seemed to slow down as I
watched it fall does precipitous
word precipitation
um it is indeed this thing goes real
deep the blood reigned precipitously
upon my face and I drank it I drank it
up with relish like rain it rained like
rain I did yes
another one anonymous
were banished from reality I got five
goose
too many too many words I mean
[Music]
and the words are dumb
[Music]
they'll do different stuff yeah I think
it's six goose
oh oh that one really been looking till
just now whoa is that blind Bart who got
that Wade I think it was inside this
thing yeah wow
that's incredible wow I wish that there
was oxygen uh-oh I really committed to
this now hey there's some oxygen I made
more Vine I made more Vine goo if you
want some are you just done with your
story now I I finished what I I slew it
I slew it
slain
i slewed i s i slow did it I sluiced it
I have eight explosive Goose that's
pretty cool see that's an impressive
record but that's sort of your own
business real thirsty down here drink
the water
yeah also the pressure's really high
that we're not pressuring you drink the
water if you want to all right I drank
oh hey buddy how you doing huh hello
me no no I'm down here in the ocean yeah
okay pretty good you're almost to the
bottom where there's
stuff did you did we did you get the was
there like a quest thing to do there was
a zip line part down there in a
blueprint ah
I don't know what the blueprint was for
but I got it I think it was for a metal
detector yeah I saw a metal detector it
was very cool yeah we need that to get
the last thing don't we yeah
yeah you have to go on the island now
and get a shovel and metal detect and
then dig up the spot oh
those are the other Zippy Parts
Ah that's very clever I think the
Blowfish might respawn here I'm not 100
sure that would be great we have enough
for eight canisters right now though
which I don't know how many other
animals on this side yes there's a goat
and a bird what which one should we get
uh
we can get both here yeah can we just
put them in the pen where Mommy lives
yeah I think so and then I'll find more
grass on the ground because they're
going to eat through it fast no they
don't eat they don't even eat through
this Lami is not that hungry you don't
think
more animals will eat more grass the the
bird won't eat the the grass I don't
think anyway
what does birds does eat it's a good
question excellent question does Bruno
Birds is eat does broom bird
eat hey wait there's a safe down here
that you didn't explore
oh it's just a crate with bolts and
leather in it you know normal ocean
floor stuff
uh and drowning a little bit but it's
okay you know what we wouldn't let you
drown an oxygen tank uh it was my own
choice to drown really it's fine
I wanted to drown
I just wanted to see if my body could
take it
yes go on go on it could oh wow
much more succinct than my story is one
copper ore worth drowning for
copper worth drowning for guess I'll
find out once I'm fully dead
man I really hope there's not a shark in
the water I am less than one shark's
bite away from Death also the the puffer
fish totally do respawn wait oh my God
we wanted to farm those they're they're
already back I'm on the way up now and
they're like oh I see one I need to make
a new spear
oh I broke my ankle but that's okay I
don't need an ankle to swim you don't
I don't think so
hmm I feel like it would make it easier
no I killed you you shouldn't be
poisoning me no how do you kill them
wait I both times I've encountered one I
made it you have to get close enough to
bear like you have to barely get close
to spear them back away quickly
go spear them again back away quickly
quickly
like you disappear him four times but
you can't stay within range of them or
they immediately break
what an annoying stupid animal yeah it's
not that bad guys
what a dumb
piece of garbage waste of carbon okay
are we completely out of wood I think we
might be pretty close yeah we we very
much are it's evening time I just
realized I haven't been drinking a lot
of water so I'm gonna drink a lot of
water in real life yeah in real life I'm
really thirsty also weird
I think the shark
on my butt did it it was chewing on
something over here oh man our boat's
taking some damage wow
hey you guys are back hey welcome back
hey what's up
how's it going how you doing I'm just
expanding the the creatures feature
before I
oh that's pretty neat um
I don't think we need seven puffer heads
do we
you never know not really no
they got a sun porch
I gave almost
dude that is fantastic actually thank
you look at how nice that is
uh we need more we need so much more uh
we're gonna have to cruise to get more
wood Fellers we're not done here yet
yeah
we'll get there though we'll get there
boys oh the Llama can't cross over these
croplets
no that's a horrible realization yeah
you can't get to the the bread or not
the bread one or the [ __ ] you can't
get to the grass that's what it is well
this is conundrum but hey at least we
can get more animals aren't we still
growing a bunch of trees nope ran out of
seeds Okay Okay do we have any Whole
Foods count mango do you got mango where
you got them you said you were hiding
them and then I didn't bother they're in
the chest man I don't know orange
somewhere not in this one wow we really
do have just an unbelievable wait here
they are five mango seeds top left chest
over here perfect it's the one I
couldn't look in because someone was in
it
while Wade was in it I think finding
what you were looking for no no I blame
him I blame him that's only fair
all right so how many uh thing parts do
we have
two let's say that somewhere yeah two in
our Journal we need to get the the metal
detector Maze We can detect the metal
and then
where did you want the finished Vine goo
at oh I have so much of that is they're
already a chest with I'm doing it I
think we used all the flying Goose I
made more
okay I have two explosive powders Mark
I'm making these canisters for you oh
for me
yeah you were our shooter weren't you I
do I did shoot it twice so I guess I
have the most experience I can go get
those animals if you'd like so this
chest this bottom small chest Mark is
the launcher and the canisters in it
okay launcher canister all right two
animals two shots that should be all I
need I'm gonna lay you down guys
I'm on it
good job buddy
I made the metal detector there fellas
no that should be great do you have like
one plank on you
I literally have four
this um board that Mark didn't want to
break with the shark is on the brink of
being broken
got it I didn't want to break it seems
like you're blaming me for things no
he's saying that you didn't want the
shark to break it but he just didn't say
it very well uh I said it well enough he
figured it out
I didn't
oh yeah but I didn't expect you to
language is meant to be communicated to
the person you're trying to talk to
which should have been me I think
no that was Bob because only Bob was
here to repair it you were already gone
ah so the one I communicated you were
just eavesdropping I apologize yes my
private conversation some Eves hey what
does this do hey guys I just pumped some
water what does that do uh I already did
that one oh okay
got it yeah that thing we got a bird
bird coming back
no what are we naming this bird
Colby Toby
Boby I gotta get Toby a nest do we have
an extra nest
there's one on the edge of the boat just
sitting there I don't know if that works
or not uh I think we had extra nests no
it blew up didn't it the great
sharpening No we got an S bird nest hell
yeah I do have two more explosive
powders Mark for canisters if we need
them let's see if I make this shot I'll
take an extra just in case I don't think
I'll miss but no you never know with me
I'm gonna grab some Stone weird finally
be used for stones
nest
that's your nest but what do birds eat I
don't even know what the hell do you eat
bird Toby oh you're here I'm putting the
canisters in that same chest okay thank
you I'm gonna go get that goat the goat
but I'm right here
I don't I think the goat I think we milk
the goat llama for fur
we need to have a container to milk it
yeah I need a bucket yes there's a
drinking glass no bucket
[ __ ] it you gotta get a bucket where is
bucket
we might not have bucket yet I don't
know how do we not have bucket
all right I think this goat was on B
Mountain but I can't remember he's up
where I ended who can happen to see my
name anywhere
oh yes that is bee Mountain
hello hello
do you have a water bottle on here I
don't sadly
[ __ ] do you have any um
fruit or anything nope
well poopies I'm gonna get this goat and
that's it
wait we do have bucket oh got it oh I
got it what's the name what's the name
boys [ __ ] goat uh
I don't want to call it I don't want to
call it the [ __ ] goat you know I
don't think us three guys on a boat
should have a goat named that
hold on
you said the first name I I guess we
have to it's because you know I all
right yeah I thought this was a
cheerocracy
all right you know what that means it's
it's now and forever dubbed the [ __ ]
goat no sorry the [ __ ] goat the
[ __ ] goat yeah [ __ ] goat really no
let's see the uh the stresses of the
syllables are really important you don't
want to stress the [ __ ] goat
what's that thing that's the opposite of
drowning oh are you slow because you're
thirsty I can barely eat oh [ __ ] oh I'm
fine yeah I'm fine all right it's fine
this is fine
hey look I really hope there's not a
shark around wait uh this is the goat
the sorry the [ __ ] goat look at that
[ __ ] goat yeah there you go good job
with the [ __ ] goat thanks man also to
make a bucket it's under the food water
tab it's three planks one scrap one rope
that does not sound like a bucket uh is
it the Bird eats like plant crops but I
thought it was just grass I don't know
no I think it's like it you need to put
like beet crops down so it can eat those
I think I have no idea I think I think
that's what it does hey what's up I
didn't I didn't successfully finish my
mission with the metal detector but now
I can come here and be alive again all
right cool
welcome back to the live
oh it's bourbon
oh sorry Bob do you need some water yeah
I know I could I could use some water
good thing we refilled all of our Waters
we always do there's one croplet
somewhere around here I know it
I know it's around here somewhere
what's a croplet it's a thing for plants
where is it
where is it where is it
well I'll just take one of the ones up
here
because I I think they're like
completely out of wood like a hundred
percent out of wood yeah yeah pretty
yeah
pretty woodless over here really it's
fine don't worry about it not even the
[ __ ] goat can help us get wood don't
don't the [ __ ] goat
don't woodry about it huh yeah
no
okay that's a little rude why can't I
build anything here because the Llama is
on here I was agreeing with you how's
that rude don't be don't be rude don't
rude no don't be rude don't be [ __ ]
rude how about that yeah
we got the well and we got the one under
the ocean do we remember where the last
one was and we need the metal detector
for it I think it's the whole thing oh
you made one of those right I have it
and I was just trying to do it until I
got thirst uh and I was thirsting
egg egg egg
we got an egg egg bars
I'm gonna eat it hell yeah oh you know
what I don't have any food this time no
what the last of our remnants of our
boat from the Yonder years I don't even
know what that means what in a joking
way the part with the bird nest and the
grill oh no so what I literally just
prepared to save like two minutes ago oh
it really wanted my planks no man we
should have really reinforced that huh
well okay Mark have you ever heard of
the ship of Theseus Mark and what about
it
well isn't this still the same boat yeah
yeah yeah I found another bird Mark what
bird there's another bird yeah I've got
it I'm like on the tower above the raft
right now I'll wait around until you can
see my name and stuff uh oh I see
movement yes where is it here it's oh
are you right is that you yeah no no I'm
down there he saw us from now I'm coming
I may come I'm coming look it's a stupid
[ __ ] bird thing
oh hey that is a really stupid [ __ ]
bird
We're Not Gonna name it the [ __ ] bird
stupid [ __ ] bird thing yeah stupid
[ __ ] bird thing okay stupid [ __ ]
bird thing all right that's what we'll
go over here he's dipping around down
here all right I hear it you got him oh
oh that would have been a good
opportunity but I know he's really
scared to eat every now and then yeah
everybody stops to eat get him got him
it's like a foot away
[ __ ] bird got ass blasted I got him
don't worry guys I wasn't worried oh
it's like I really got an Akron in this
okay Mark there's pigs up here too we
might need to get pigs no the pigs are
violent well maybe we don't need to
catch pigs all right it couldn't fit
stupid [ __ ] bird thing so it's uh
it's named stupid bird nope stupid ah I
wish it was [ __ ] bird it's not well
we both wish
it's just it's just bird you know what
they say about wishes welcome
shut up you [ __ ] idiot wow that was
graceful thanks Bob you're welcome I
just I just walked to the edge and was
like if I walk off will I fly to where I
want to go
ah darn it nah it didn't work that's
crazy oh someone drank no someone put
water in someone refilled a water thing
unlike some heathens there's a thing
over here uh on top of one of the uh
pillars that says requires one explosive
daughter
we've got milk milk oh dude sick Bro
Mark can you check those little tiny
chests if you're still on the boat and
see if there's any explosive powder in
any of them why I think it's a powder in
one of the chests oh like I see
interesting because if we not we have to
find a way to cook one to do the thing
Bob found yeah we gotta explicit about
her yeah how many we got two okay Bob we
have two but we have two
where the goat was uh there's an
explosive powder thing that it needs an
explosive powder yeah I'm on the way
wait let me drink first I'm on the way
zipline part not is a zipline part yeah
that's pretty dumb
it's a good thing this metal detector
doesn't detect all this other metal
that's not the metal we want
um
it is plot convenient it's a correct
metal detector little known fact where
am I going
where the goat was hmm Roger on Route
and Route n root and and on
Route on
Route Daddy
what
what
on Daddy route I'm saying that you're on
Route Eddie all right what okay uh who
who do I blow
me all right I'm coming oh get ready to
be blown wow
where's it going where's it going well
that can't be good oh okay
wait do you see that thing in this yeah
what is that thing what is that thing is
that what we need parachuting is that
what that's happening
I didn't even realize we could go over
there
it's fine
oh God
I win that's what I am right whatever
I'm a winner
Bob just ran by inside this trailer oh
get him pick him up then
whoa It's a zipline part yay an adult
like a sex doll no it's not a it's not
yeah no it's a [ __ ] doll it's not
it's not [ __ ] doll for [ __ ] I
don't think so yeah it is how do I get
up there from here oh I should climb I
don't know yeah who who's going to make
the zip line
um
uh dude there's uh not doing that I can
do it I guess
I need to go get water first though
firework
hey wait do you need some water yes can
I already feel oh God you can take fall
damage
oh please the fall day whoops
the whole damage is not very much and I
almost just tested it uh-huh yeah hey
look wait a puffer fish
although we could always use more if you
come to where I is I have water for you
I have a full water bottle I was just
being greedy wow
didn't get the puffer fish and shut up
okay well I guess we didn't put it I'm
not getting the video yeah you heard you
yeah
all right well who's getting the other
thing wait guys I have to tell you this
and I'm very excited about it have you
ever seen the the mocking cactuses I've
probably told you about this before I
went no when would you have told us
about that it's a children's toy we one
of which we got as a gift for uh our
soon-to-be son it's a little Cactus and
when it hears a sound it plays it back
but it does it in my voice that I do
it like it like speeds it up so if he
says it'd be like hey Cactus it'd be
like okay
and he dances when he talks no
no oh cut out
that's fine it's fine a plank I think
I'll swim for this a plank a plank and
maybe take up his got it gosh so many
eggs God we're swimming an egg
are you sure we're done with the zipline
thing well you gotta make the zip line
then you gotta go on the zip line
I'm sure we could make the zipline yes
you literally into the top building and
there's like a crafting area are you
tell me you got to make an individual
bucket for every time you want to milk
this goddamn goat yes guys I got planks
chopping down the trees jumping down
trees that's right you did just the
trees that's right the churches yes I
went to the wrong one there's not many
buildings I'm gonna put these planks in
one of the chest Finders Keepers
foreign
house
why do I sound drunk yeah well that was
my question too really
[Music]
I found some old Scottish whiskey I
don't really want to go back in the
island I gotta be honest I don't either
I'm already up here I think
let's just make Wade do it
that sounds good hey do you want to hang
out uh do you want to have a bath yeah
let's have a bath
hey guys I had to get a blueprint for
the zipline tool ah I see I see all
right
oh man
oh the bath is so nice oh
oh
this lovely ah man learn how to relax
guys
I yeah you got both okay okay right dude
right right right right right right yeah
you look so chill in there thanks thanks
I feel chill
oh you navigating you navigating well
you said no see that's the thing this is
my Captain's couch I can Captain the
boat from this couch that's awesome
right see you I knew you'd appreciate
this there's a lot of different ways to
go with the zip line now when you guys
want to come I don't know I didn't take
the in the Grandeur you know there's
really a lot of grandeur in here yeah no
there is you're right there is yeah this
is good stuff man you should be proud of
this you should be proud well I chose
one of the paths with the zip line are
you winning son yeah you keep it up
buddy you keep it up out there
oh my God you can play this game in
third person what can you how
comma puts it it puts you into third
person you could do this is oh look at
me man hey it got a battery charger
blueprint getting kind of pink why why
are my arms pink oh no I need a mare
chest key do any of you have a mirror
chest key how do I get out of the bath
uh it's probably hit the e or something
oh good let's see yeah why are my limbs
so pink in my kind of pink face is so
not your face is the same color as my
body but your limbs are like the wrong I
don't know like must be super sunburn oh
it's like Adam Levine your body's so
[ __ ] body
yeah keep on those zip lines buddy keep
I don't want to look at my face yeah
what are you finding you finding good
stuff I need to find a mare key
this is not going to be as the short one
person thing oh yeah all right yeah I'm
not gonna I'm not gonna replace the
water or anything I'm just gonna chill
in here why would you why would you
don't Man You're Gonna Keep On soloing
this I guess it goes on in the tub
well they love that for you by myself me
too yeah more wait no I found piles of
dirt I don't have a shovel uh no no one
has a shovel I don't think sorry yeah no
you both do you both have shovels
I don't think so yeah I don't think so
either
oh sharks attacking
uh shark really took out some of our
boat we could use some wood oh man you
gotta watch out for those guys I have 10
Planks on me making 11. they're
capricious I am literally trying to get
over there okay I I quit my bath early
just just because you're selfish it
needs to come before mine
okay so I'm coming just calm down yeah
me too make sure you bring a zip line
tool and equip it
yep calm down Alma day
which zip line do I want to do right now
that's the question there's one to the
mayor's house leads to the dirt
I haven't gone the other way but the
mayor's house also needs a key that I
haven't found yet it's supposed to be
coming to you yes because you're
complaining not anymore
did you dig up the dirt piles well no
I'm just no longer there what was your
concern Mark when did we get the zip
lines
relaxing
but how did they how did it get in my
inventory it just appeared in your
inventory when Wade did the thing do you
guys do you guys need me over there yes
no probably not all right let's stick
around here we're okay probably
definitely yeah yeah unless I should get
over there huh yes
no I mean do what you want uh
oh yeah actually I'll do what I want
ah this is it this is it this is it this
is it guys
I think he's on to something I am on to
something excellent good good stuff I
found more bees yes yes yes all right
I'm on the way guys
don't worry I'm on the way
thanks bud I'm on the way oh these pigs
are very scary where are you guys what's
up what's going on I'm using one
infirmary key
oh my God these pigs are rough where are
you hey look I have a note and a mayor's
chesky that's handy
wow I don't care where we are where are
you I'm on board I see I see I see okay
riding zipline
oh you have to jump I see yeah or you
bounce hilariously all right no not you
okay uh there he is there's the man
there's pigs
okay once you're over here you're safe
all right good good here
huh I've got something for you
oh God did you know the pigs could hit
you even on a rock wow look at that I
know right oh my God I'm getting
annihilated by pigs pretty good oh it's
almost like you don't need to bite them
I'm dead literally dead are you dead yep
we're there I'm dead all standing and a
pile of pigs hmm interesting Mark all
right let's flip them up I've got him ow
rescued oh
uh can I ride a zip line with you we'll
find out
well
you cannot
[Music]
um
oh man uh
I think we gotta jump for it I think
we'll make it
oh
God took it on my shins don't worry guys
I'm at the mayor's house now we'll be
done soon all right good did you get the
mayor's key yes oh good good work this
is jumping help or hurt engine controls
is a separate thing oh my God this is
everything I've ever wanted in life
you can have it up in your house I know
I know that's not what I thought I was
gonna get if I'm being honest but yeah I
thought there would be something else
here we didn't really have to have that
oh yeah I mean it's very convenient but
that is pretty convenient it wasn't a
necessity I don't think do you think
that we'll ever get to the point where
we redo our entire boat like from the
ground up oh God we should just start
over I'm good we've lost
we don't have any wood we need to just
go get wood
yes well I thought we were gonna uh
[ __ ] how we're gonna be douched what
what are we douching that we were
Diggity Diggity done dog apparently we'd
Diggity done
I thought you were Diggity done somebody
you said you take it he had to go I
don't know you're talking about
I thought we had all the time in the
world what happened what happened what
happened oh well I'm coming back to the
boat I guess I think we're done
exploring this island did we get any
more
um another
code because until we get another code
we're not done
but we got a lot of notes yeah you know
what I don't know we did or not
no we did it might have been in the
mayor's house but just buried in there
that probably was the last place to go I
got I got like a note
wait I see a separate thing out here
with an with a zip line to it let me see
if that's it maybe it's like
off on its own
okay it doesn't look like there's
anything else besides those there's a
blind too but what do I know damn it
actually there's two zipline like
secondary places to go after you get to
the mayor but no that just leads back to
where that was already yeah there's a
lot of zip lines that are mainly just
going back and forth hmm
I'll just double check the mayor's area
just in case oh there's a new note hey
look at that uh this code tangaroa I got
it oh okay well I'm an idiot ah it's not
stupid
well you are getting older yeah
and you oh no is that the Kraken